[Musique]
même si on nous demande de partager des
données il y a aucune condition
d'atteinte des résultats donc notre seul
imputabilité c'est face à nos citoyens
donc dans ce sens-là
quand même on chemine dans bonne
direction que pas de conditions mais
pour ce qui est du montant total ben
c'est nettement insuffisant François
Legault n'a pas caché sa déception
sortir de sa rencontre sur les
transferts en santé avec Justin Trudeau
et ses homologues provinciaux il semble
résigner accepter l'offre le premier
ministre du Québec promet qu'il
continuera à réclamer davantage de fonds
pour financer son plan santé et corriger
ce qu'il qualifie de souffrance
chronique du système mais quel impact
cela aura-t-il sur le prochain budget de
la province j'en discute avec le
ministre des Finances Éric Girard que je
retrouve dans ses bureaux de Montréal tu
Gérard bonjour merci d'être avec nous
c'est un plaisir merci Gérard vous aviez
vous souhaitiez obtenir 6 milliards de
plus par année en transfert récurrents
vous en avez obtenu un en vertu de
l'entente avec le gouvernement ou de
l'offre du gouvernement fédéral de la
semaine dernière qu'est-ce que ça comme
impact sur votre budget
en fait au niveau de notre budget ça n'a
pas l'impact parce que nous nous sommes
engagés depuis longtemps à donner les
ressources au ministre du B pour
exécuter son plan
[Musique]
santé et là on est dans l'exécution puis
on veut faire une différence pour les
citoyens d'ici deux ans la santé c'est
une responsabilité des provinces le
Québec va mettre les ressources qui sont
nécessaires pour faire une différence
les citoyens mais c'est une opportunité
manquée pour le gouvernement fédéral de
ramener sa contribution là où elle était
à la fin des années 80 comment vous
faites pour dire que les gens
d'argumentaire ça donne ça en
négociation quand vous dites j'aurais
voulu avoir plus d'argent mais j'en ai
pas plus pas grave je peux quand même
faire le travail mais c'est à dire que
on a des obligations
c'est une responsabilité de la province
c'est notre plus gros poche budgétaire
43% et c'est aussi notre poste
budgétaire qui augmente le plus
rapidement alors c'est certain que le
gouvernement fédéral qui contribuait
autrefois
plus de 10% supplémentaires ça part
décliner dans le temps et et lorsqu'on
demandait aux fédéral c'est d'être un
partenaire pour l'amélioration des soins
de santé au Québec et le fédéral choisi
de déposer une offre qui somme toute est
marginales pour nous on nous donne la
proximativement un milliard par année de
plus sur un budget qui totalise plus de
55 milliards c'est vraiment
les sommes fédérales sont marginales
alors c'est pas ça qui va faire la
différence le gouvernement fédéral dit
que il y a une façon un peu un peu
malhonnête de calculer parce que on a
l'impression que vous calculez pas les
provinces calcule pas les points
d'impôts il y a une différence quand
même les points d'impôts vous avez
obtenu en 1900 à la fin des années 70 ça
ramène le niveau de financement du
gouvernement fédéral un peu plus haut
non
oui ça donne 10% de plus mais on les
avait aussi
dans les années 80 donc on parle d'un
chiffre plus haut alors qu'on ajoute les
points d'impôts ou non qu'on les compte
ou non ça donne la même chose la peur du
fédéral dans les soins de santé au
Canada a diminué de façon significative
dans le temps et oui si vous ajoutez les
points d'impôts en dollars de 2023 vous
ajoutez un 10%, mais vous devez finir
10% plus haut est-ce que les belles
impôts que vous avez promises pourraient
être mis en péril ou est-ce que c'est
encore sage de promettre des baisses
d'impôts dans ce contexte
mais en fait les baisses d'impôts d'une
part elles sont justifiées parce que
ralentissement économique et que les
Québécois ont le fardeau fiscal le plus
élevé au Canada ce que j'ai expliqué
plusieurs fois c'est que le choix que
nous proposons au québecois c'est de
réduire le fardeau fiscal en réduisant
moins vite le poids de la dette parce
qu'on est on a un plan au Québec pour
réduire le poids de la dette on est sur
une trajectoire à long terme de
réduction de la dette et ce que nous
proposons c'est de réduire cette dette
moins vite pour financer la baisse
d'impôts il n'y a donc aucun lien entre
la baisse d'impôts et le niveau des
services par exemple en santé ou en
éducation au Québec mais ça vous donne
moins de flexibilité il y a quand vous
quand vous l'argent vous allez pas
percevoir n'allez pas j'ai contribuables
vous pouvez pas la réinvestir dans des
soins de santé ou dans la construction
de nouvelles écoles il y a une banque au
Québec nous il y a pas de lien entre le
financement de l'éducation de la santé
de la des impôts parce que nous avons
une noix au Québec la Loi sur la gestion
de la dette et le fond de génération
dans cette loi nous devons contribuer
cette année 3 milliards de dollars
dans le fond les générations et ça
augmente à 5 milliards de dollars à la
cinquième année alors ce que nous
proposons c'est que les contributions
font les générations les réduire pour
financer
la réduction de fardeau fiscal toujours
un mot sur la question de de l'âge
d'accessibilité au régime de retraite
des consultations
à 62 ans pourquoi est-ce que c'est
important pourquoi d'après vous ça
devient important de repousser cet
âge-là
mais en fait nous ce qu'on a c'est un
régime qui est en santé et en vertu de
la loi on doit faire une consultation
publique à tous les six ans et lorsqu'on
a mis des propositions sur la table il y
a des consultations publiques et ce
qu'on montre c'est que l'espérance de
vie en 2030 aura augmenté de 9 ans c'est
un peu plus pour les femmes puis un peu
moins plaisantes de 9 ans en moyenne que
les gens étudient de deux à trois ans de
plus donc la période d'accumulation de
revenus de la retraite par rapport à la
période où nous sommes à la retraite et
plus courte ou une autre façon de dire
ça les actuaires diraient la longévité
s'est accrue et donc c'est important
d'avoir des revenus de retraite plus
élevés une façon d'avoir des revenus de
retraite plus élevés si vous prenez
votre régime des lentes à 60 ans versus
le prend à 62 ans vous revenus de
retraite jusqu'à votre décès c'est une
très longue période seront 23% plus
élevé donc on veut prendre la bonne
santé financière où on suggère en fait
les bilans on écoute on suggère que
prendre la bonne d'utiliser une portion
de la bonne santé financière du régime
pour accroître la sécurité financière
des Québécois est-ce que c'est un pas
vers le passage de l'âge de la retraite
de 65 à 67 ans c'est un peu seul vous
repousser tout ça deux ans non non
en fait présentement on a un régime 60
65 70 c'est à dire que votre 30
la rente à 100% de la rendre à 65 ans
elle est bonifiée si vous le retarder
elle est réduite jusqu'à 36 %, si vous
le prenez à 60 ans Alors ce qu'on ce qui
est proposé dans le régime dans le
consultation c'est 62 65 72
on a eu deux jours de consultation
plusieurs mémoires je vous dirais qu'en
général les actuaires sont favorables et
les on a vu que les mouvements de
travailleurs et s'y opposaient c'est
très important qu'on comprenne pourquoi
ici oppose et là ils nous ont expliqué
leur point de vue je vous dirai que
certains on doit faire une meilleure
communication mieux expliquer mais
encore une fois si les analyses montrent
que trop de perdants dans un changement
qu'on veut faire pour le bénéfice de
l'ensemble mais on va pondérer ça on
écoute c'est pour ça qu'on a des
consultations
Eric Gérard ministre des Finances du
Québec merci d'avoir été là merci
beaucoup